joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is one of my favorites
he's one of the all-time greats at doing
what he does
for uh football night in america and
sunday night football the perennial emmy
award nominee and winner uh getting set
for a big sunday night game with al
michaels in las vegas nevada for the
chargers and the raiders on nbc chris
collinsworth here on the rich eisen show
how you doing chris
what's happening brother
that's a loaded question
[Laughter]
so let's talk about the football aspect
of this because god wins out and um you
recall in that game uh when michelle
tafoya gave that report before godwin
got hurt that brown was coming back
now he's gone
playoff lenny might be less than what do
you make of the buck's chances of
repeating right now as we're sitting
here prior to week 18 knowing what we
know about who's at brady and aryan's
disposal
well they still have tom brady right yes
they do sure about that one correct and
um so
when we know that brady can go into
uh
green bay and win a game we're pretty
sure about that one
um i i think it's way too early to say
they can't do it i mean they've got
tyler johnson's a nice player obviously
grog they could go three tight ends if
they wanted to and
build the game plan i think where you
get hurt is when
something like that happens in the
middle of the game
and you have no idea but when you can
game plan around
antonio brown now i i mean would you
rather have them yeah you'd rather have
them but
i don't know
not under these circumstances
chris collinsworth here uh on the rich
eisen show would you say green bay then
is in fact
not just by you know do of their one
seed but by
what you have seen including what you
just saw chris the team to beat
in the entire nfl right now with a week
to go in the regular season
yeah i i think you have to go there with
that team now they they just
they're
they've got the hot quarterback you know
and they've got enough around it and you
think that maybe
they end up getting a few of these
people back you know the does bacchiari
come back does jayer alexander come back
um
does uh does josh myers come back
through center right so there's all
kinds of different things out there that
that could come into play here
um but i think even if you just go um
that's it you know we're going to play
with what we have based on what i've
seen they seem to be
uh the most consistent
team and really one of the main reasons
why
i mean the result douglas has been
unfrickin believable their quarterback
five interceptions a couple of pick
sixes game winners
i mean it's just it's been phenomenal
what this
guy who is released and on practice
squads has come in there
and done for this football team and
covering up the whole left by jair
alexander
so uh is brady is uh brady rogers who's
your mvp because i'm you also have all
those pff
uh pieces of information in front of you
war and things like that that you can
actually put everything together chris
um and put together a pretty solid
thought having seen these guys in front
row all year long what do you have for
me on that yeah
i'm this is how bad a boss i am i
i went out on national television and uh
and said that i would take rogers
and um
obviously uh pff is said tom brady
so
you know sometimes
that's how it works out but i i really
believe and now brady's in a little bit
of the same boat too
um
with the with the injuries and the
different things but i mean you go down
the list here of what brady has been
missing this year
i mean bhakti ari elton jenkins who's
probably their second best lineman the
rookie josh myers who was their starting
center billy turner now out for extended
time the only
consistent player up front
has been royce newman the rookie and
then you have robert tunian who is his
top tight end right you have randall
cobb who's out now uh going down the
list so i i think that
as i watch them play
this season without aaron rodgers
you go how many games does this team win
without him
and you know where we see kansas city i
guess was the game that we saw without
in kansas city obviously is a good team
but it was the offense that just didn't
score
or get it done in that game so
um
i i you know it's the old pull em off
your team and what happens to your team
pff will tell you tom brady
my eyeballs have told me aaron rodgers
but i think it's really close
chris collinsworth here on the rich
eisen show and obviously you've got one
of the greatest front row seats um for
sunday night football but a literal one
there in cincinnati for a bengals team
that is just so terrific
with joe burrow
and jamar chase right now how good do
you think the bengals can be right now
in these playoffs that they have
gotten at least one
home game
um sealed and cemented what do you think
about that one chris
yeah i i
the interesting thing about this team as
far as i'm concerned is
they are the team that if you had to say
all right of the other afc teams in the
playoffs
you know who has a chance to go score
points with kansas city because that's
probably in buffalo you know some
uh
so i would say cincinnati does now can
they hold up on defense does this
offensive line hold up
under playoff sort of pressure
i don't know but i tell you i'll take
joe burrow
t higgins
tyler boyd cj uzama and jamar chase and
go play anybody and and
um
you know they're
they're running back here tough so i i
think this is a team that is very much
uh has the possibility
of being
of being that high scoring team i tend
to think they're probably
a year away
but joe burrow has been the best player
in college football that pff has ever
seen
last year came out and was brilliant as
a rookie
got hurt how many quarterbacks do we see
come back and
be terrible the year after aeneas right
if anything he was the best he's ever
been
um
and and jamar chase
the two biggest games of the year that i
thought cincinnati played this year
were
at baltimore to sort of create that
paradigm shift that they can compete
there
they blow out the ravens there and he's
going against marlon humphrey who for my
money is one of the best quarterbacks in
all of football he put on a phenomenal
show
and against kansas city
i thought the game was over they're 14
to nothing in
cincinnati and all of a sudden jamar
chase did what he's done all season long
which is catch one makes seven people
miss score touchdown and all of a sudden
you're like hey
14-7 hey you know they kind of chanted
they were down 14 again and then they
got lucky with the kickoff return
getting called back so there were a lot
of things that happened
but as far as a guy that his teammates
look at him
and believe that these two guys have
magic within them
joe burrow and jamar chase come about as
close to the top of that list right now
for a an organization that isn't one of
the rock star organizations that you can
name chris collinsworth here on the rich
eisen show and chris you've called uh
thousands of games have you ever called
a game where a winner goes in lose or
goes home but both teams
just are going to take 90 kneel downs
because they both get in with a tie you
ready for that for sunday night football
with the chargers hey the raiders
what do you think i'm just and where is
that game played in las vegas there
might be a revolution up there um
i mean it is bizarre but okay let me lay
this scenario yes sir do i think that
they're gonna do
you know take a knee the whole game i
don't i don't i don't think that's a
possibility
do i think that somehow if the first
game
you know goes the way that these two
teams need and you end up with two
minutes to go in overtime that's right
in some bizarre way yep and you're kind
of looking over at the other bench and
maybe there's
somebody has timeouts left
and you just kind of go all right i'm
going to take this first knee
and if they call a timeout then game's
on
that's the smoke signal that's the
signal that could that be the smoke
signal i don't know i mean you know what
i mean i mean your job as a coach
in the playoffs yes correct get your it
doesn't matter how it doesn't matter how
you do it
if you're telling me they're down to the
last minute minute and a half two
minutes of that game
and
you can take a knee and guarantee
your team is in the playoffs i mean you
hand it off they might fumble and return
it for a touchdown
we've seen that before right so if
if taking a knee at the end of that game
to play for a tie
is what you do to get in your team in
the playoffs i absolutely do that and i
mean how many times have we seen this in
the past we we argue about it
all the time you know with with teams
that
don't play their starters and it's going
to impact somebody else's playoff
position and going to guarantee somebody
doesn't get in the playoffs but you have
the right to do what is in your best
interest for your team to make the
playoffs
and do i think any of this is going to
happen i 100 do not think it is do i
think that if i were in that position at
the end of the game and i could kneel
down and play for a tie that put my team
into the playoffs when i do it you're
darn right of course no doubt about it
and for this to happen the ravens have
to or the steelers have to beat the
ravens and then the jaguars have to
somehow pull it all together to beat a
colts team that is in a win-and-in
scenario and then you know a tie would
get both the chargers and the raiders in
and i had brandon staley on the show
tuesday and i asked him point blank
would you do it and uh i apologize for
asking that question of a of an nfl head
coach
uh
in advance and he's just like of course
not you know like we respect the game
too much but your point is exactly right
like let's just say this does go to
overtime because you can't lose the game
if you lose the game you're out you have
to force overtime overtime is forced and
then they try to win whoever gets the
toss tries to win the game gets three
points the other team gets three points
and it's like a minute and a half to go
what does that team do
and then maybe that's the smoke signal
i'm gonna take a knee here and the other
team burns a timeout you're like all
right screw it now that you just cost
yourself a playoff spot or do you just
let the time run out
i would let the time run out you're in
right that's it i would let it i i heard
somebody say that
let's take the the worst case scenario
they that they take a knee from the
beginning of the game and
do it all the way through
the commissioner we have the power at
that point to declare a double forfeit
right
and that's it neither one neither one of
you are going to the playoffs based on
what you did
i don't think any of that would happen
in the scenario where it's in the game
though i don't yeah i've got fred
godelli by the way on in hour three
because i want to talk madden with him
just you know i'd love to i'd love to
hear his stories and uh you know your
producer fred and and you know
i'm gonna ask him later on you know uh
can you flex out of a game after one
kneel down in the first quarter like
there's no other games you can flex into
you're out you're done you're there
you're in vegas you and al maybe you and
i could go grab a stake at that point
you and i could just go grab a stake if
something like that happens oh as an
announcer yeah we would be killing that
from an announcer standpoint
man now you get to go anywhere you want
with anything you want it would be it
would be like talk radio baby and i did
that for a long time yes you did and uh
chris collinsworth here on the rich
eisen show and you were kind enough to
be on my podcast just getting started
about the origin stories of
of uh of of my guests and it was an nfl
voices of the nfl season and before i
let you go i'd love to hear a story that
i had no idea that before al michaels
came over to nbc the idea that dick ever
saw the grand poobah of nbc sports for
so many years was to have you and madden
in the booth together
calling the game together and you
actually did an audition to make it just
or just just a try out just to see
because you're already there with nbc
but just to see you know what's what
what was that like you and madden
in a booth together calling a game you
know in quotes
chris what was that like they flew us
out
like the entire nbc sports department
john madden has that studio you've
probably been out there
in pleasanton or pleasantville or
whatever pleasanton yeah yeah
yeah and and
so they flew us on like a 747 pick me up
in cincinnati flew
everybody out there this plane had two
bedrooms on it i was like what the heck
so we go out and we sit in the studio
and
and
we're just gonna call a playoff game
that's happening it was denver and
somebody
and
the theory was that they were going to
have me do play-by-play
and john do caller but really not really
do play-by-play just kind of both of us
you know talk about the game
and so we did it um
and
honestly i
i was terrible i i'm just gonna tell you
when you you know i was just like i knew
i'm sure other people knew whatever so
we get finished afterwards
and
and uh so i'm sitting there with dick
and he goes oh you know
that went really well and i went okay
and uh he goes i want you to know that
the job is yours if you want it if you
want to do play-by-play with john
the job is yours
so there's a big pregnant pause there
and then he comes back and he goes
or
i think i have a chance to get al
michaels
and i just started laughing out loud i
can remember it like it was just i said
are you crazy
you got a chance to go go get out
michaels are you nuts i go come on dick
that's the biggest no-brainer of a
choice i've ever heard my whole life but
i do like to tell uh mike and al boat
but that neither one of them would have
had a job but for me
well but again obviously i know it's
your job to to watch everything except
the ball right so now here you are in a
position calling a game that you're
supposed to watch the ball but uh but
what what was it like you know how to be
out of body just sitting there calling a
game with madden right just sitting
there it was awesome
right yeah no it was great fun we were
having a good time and if i had it to do
over again i probably wouldn't
do any play-by-play right right i would
just sit there like the manning cast
right like the manning cast doesn't
really like the manning cast exactly
like okay
you got to figure out who has the ball
or maybe i would at least just tell who
caught the ball or something like that
but it's really intriguing to be sitting
next to that man you know there's so
many different things that he's done in
his lifetime
and
just the fact that i got to do that
right was so cool for me i
i just said do i think it would have
evolved into something that could have
been fun
yeah i think i think we would have
survived the day
but come on al michaels and john madden
versus
chris calhoun's doing play-by-play with
john madden that was that was a
no-brainer chris have a great time on
sunday night personally we think whoever
wins the toss their first place should
be a fake knee and then throw deep and i
think that should be the raiders i think
that would be that would be like in
honor of al davis and and madden to just
fake the knee and then throw deep and
then just try and win the game oh like
that would be great
light the flame there in that stadium
there you go that's gonna be a heck of a
night you know obviously it's their
first home game since the passing of of
uh of john madden and the fact that
you're there and sunday night football
is there it's going to be great i can't
wait for so much on the line i
appreciate the call enjoy it
all right buddy thanks yeah we'll see
out here in l.a for the super bowl we'll
check it out that's chris collins with
everybody should check out pro football
focus as well sunday night football hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here